gloom sets in who do the people in here
really work for the public or their pain
masters and with the news jeffrey cox
was doing a second job abroad many in
here are now asking are we properly
watching the watchers
today i asked the speaker who was
visiting a special remembrance garden in
front of the commons
what he made of jeffrey cox working from
the british virgin islands when you saw
a member of this house
voting from the british virgin islands
because he was taking paid work did you
think it was the right thing to do
what i would say is
that of course we've all seen the media
that says that somebody's earning a lot
of money overseas the fact is as you
quite said he's broke no rules but i'll
tell you what
we will all be judged by the electorate
including that said member
tory woes deepened as jeffrey cox's
spokesman released this bullish
statement so jeffrey's view is that it's
up to the electors of torridge and west
devon whether or not they vote for
someone who is a senior and
distinguished professional in his field
and who still practices that profession
he also pointed the finger at the man
who should keep a grip on standards and
behavior tory chief whip mark spencer
for agreeing he could work overseas
mark spencer himself a farmer in his
spare time who runs this farm and shop
has had a bruising few weeks first over
owen patterson and now this
the chief whip is getting the heat but
it's boris johnson who doesn't want to
budge there are ideas for improving
things in the commons like salary caps
on outside earnings but the prime
minister at the press conference today
made clear he thinks the system is
broadly fine he doesn't want the
conflict it would bring with his own
side there might eventually be some
changes like removing passes from some
ex-mps but it'll all be tinkering around
the edges
labour's deputy leader angela rainer
today wrote to the watchdog over jeffrey
cox's two jobs if being an mp is full
time how does she do all of her roles to
be honest if you ask my friends and
family they say i don't because i don't
really do anything about that my life is
dedicated to my job as the deputy leader
and as the mp for ashton underline
some tory mps say privately they are
finding the sleaze allegations and their
handling so stressful it's affecting
their mental health can boris johnson
improve things sam coates sky news